imagine you're shooting a scene from
Black Panther wakanda Forever on a
motorcycle and suddenly you go flying
through the air terrifying right well
let me be the one to tell you terrifying
moments like that happen on movie sets
so much more than you think and not just
to Leticia right obviously what everyone
is talking about right now is this whole
Alec Baldwin rust nonsense and I've been
waiting to get in on it because while
there are some onset tragedies that were
just awful accidents like the shooting
of Brandon Lee on the set of the crow
the shooting on the set of rust was an
entirely different story basically Alec
Baldwin was passed a gun that he thought
was loaded with a blank when it was
actually loaded with a live round so he
ended up striking Helena Hutchins and
taking her life people rushed to
Baldwin's defense but people in the biz
were much more confused why in the heck
was a live round being used in this film
at all even if it was a blank why was
Baldwin pointing the gun at an actual
person and where was the person in
charge of all these loaded guns the big
problem involves the hiring of Hannah
Gutierrez read as the film's head armor
you know the people in charge of gun
safety only the problem with her was
that on her only other film as head
armor the old way with Nicholas Cage she
was criticized by the cast and crew for
not being very good at gun safety like
evidently she almost flew Cage's eardrum
out by not announcing she was firing a
gun and even she admitted to this in an
interview when she literally said that
she didn't like working with blanks
because she didn't really know how they
worked huh who would have ever thought
this Pro would have caused an onset
accident in her defense she fired back
at the film's producers for making an
unsafe environment trust me the
environment of a film can make all the
difference but even on nysat's accidents
still happen I mean think about the
trauma Leticia Wright and Dylan O'Brien
went through seriously Leticia Wright
wound up in the hospital even though she
was working on what might be the best
film set of all time like anyone else
love how the cast and crew behind Black
Panther movies are basically their own
family these guys are having too much
fun making movies that emotionally
devastate me when Leticia Wright got
injured filming that big motorcycle
chase scene the fun stopped real quick
the entire cast rallied around her after
she was injured with a fractured
shoulder and a concussion among other
injuries but it seems like the real
damage here was psychological which I
totally get being thrown off a
motorcycle at high speeds yeah I'd be a
little traumatized too luckily though
Wright managed to get not only the
medical care she needed but the therapy
she needed as well that kind of warm
environment helped her heal inside and
out so she could come back to work and
beat the little ankle Wings right off of
Namor and ditto that for Dylan O'Brien
when he went through almost the exact
same thing in Maze Runner the death
cures similar motorcycle stunt like the
cast seriously thought that that was for
O'Brien when he went down so hard that
he got a concussion brain trauma and a
facial fracture that required
reconstructive surgery and after all
that O'Brien also talked about how the
psychological recovery was harder than
anything else even today he still
struggles with severe anxiety anytime
he's on set even though the physical
injuries have healed and if I've said
this once I swear I've said it a
thousand times it doesn't matter if
you're an actor a superhero or just work
in paycheck to paycheck self-care is
important that's why when I get to do my
own big Marvel movie or why a film
adaptation should be any day now
honestly I'm gonna have a stunt
performer ride that motorcycle for me
they do this kind of dangerous stuff for
so much less recognition
seriously you wouldn't believe how much
this happens to stunt workers and most
people don't even know their names but
don't worry I brought the receipts Joy
Harris had a similar motorcycle stunt on
Deadpool 2 that sent her through the
plate glass window of a building which
costed her her life and the production
three hundred thousand dollars in fines
but that's not as important here
stuntman Jerry Fitzgerald was supposed
to pretend to get struck with an arrow
on the Avengers and fall off a building
only his foot got caught on the way down
slamming his head into a brick wall he
literally lost a chunk of his scalp I
can't even imagine and then the man
actually got up and did several more
takes like what David Holmes was Daniel
Radcliffe stunt double through most of
the Harry Potter films that is until he
had his head jerked back during a broom
flying sequence breaking his neck and
permanently paralyzing him from the
chest down then there's the set of
Resident Evil the Final Chapter which
was a rust Style Danger Fest that cost
stuntwoman Olivia Jackson an arm after
being asked to do an unrehearsed
motorcycle sequence yeah unrehearsed
afterwards she got a cheeky tattoo of
one of those scissor cutting dotted
lines right above her amputation then
we've got Joe Watts who was supposed to
be thrown over a building on a wire
during the filming of F9 but ended up
falling 25 feet into concrete which
resulted in some serious injuries now I
don't know about you but I think if
these people can get thrown off of
buildings and then do another take then
they deserve Oscars that makes me so
freaking mad but you know what really
makes me mad is when people question why
a scene needs a stunt performer at all
okay sure Tom Cruise and piano freaking
Reeves can do all their stunts all day
but 9 out of 10 actors really need to
rely on a professional so they can focus
on their job of you know acting well
even a big time movie director like
Quentin Tarantino fell into this same
trap when it came time from a girl Uma
Thurman to do her epic I'm gonna recap
the last movie but in such an intense
way you don't even notice monologue from
Kill Bill Vol 2 she had a huge
disagreement with cute as to how they
should film the scene basically that she
didn't want to actually be driving a car
while doing her lines now to Mr
Tarantino it was like what's the big
deal you can't act and drive at the same
time get over it so Uma being the
awesome professional that she is decided
to give it a shot and wouldn't you know
it she drove right into a tree it turns
out that acting along with stunt work
requires a lot more than people realize
even if they are oscar-winning directors
so moral of the story never disagree
with Uma Thurman you know what never
disagree with Ethan Hawke or Maya Hawk
either that whole family is straight
gold but seriously how do these stunt
performers not get Oscars doesn't that
just tick you off too please let me hear
all about it in the comments